homosexuality is an adaptation
not an inborn trait wow and she is a gay
activist
but she's honest
is there any reason to rethink what the
bible has to say about homosexuality
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
hey everybody welcome to led live today
we have a really great ministry
colleague friend of ours here to join us
ron woolsey is part of coming out
ministries perhaps you guys have seen
some of the work that we've done with
his other co-founder michael carducci
but we've been blessed by having your
ministry kind of come and teach us a few
things but today's topic i know is a hot
button topic
and there are a lot of questions and we
are starting to see a lot of people
trying to
re-examine
or reframe maybe what the bible has to
say on the topic of homosexuality and so
um ron thank you for coming by to bless
us today well thank you it's a it's a
real pleasure for me to be here
uh you know
it appears that
the authority of the word of god is
under full
assault today in the world
i said in the world
but unfortunately it's also under salt
in the church
in the christian church
and one example and this is what i
wanted to talk about today
is a fairly new book that has come out
it's called unclobber
rethinking our misuse of the bible
our misuse of the bible
on homosexuality the premise right there
is kind of like you need to stop beating
me over the head exactly
he gets a whole message right there on
the cover of the book and the author is
colby martin
and he is the pastor
he was actually
let go by his own church because of his
stand
and he started another
community type church or
non-denominational church
but
i wanted to talk about
that book and kind of do a review of
that today but
but first of all i like to lay the
foundation
from the word of god the very word of
god that is that is under attack today
in proverbs we see that god's word is
referred to as the way of life
reproofs of instruction or the way of
life
and in first john 4 verse 8 we are told
that god is love and i think it's
important for us to
to make this the foundation of our whole
discussion that god
is love so everything in the word of god
comes from the heart of love
and
some things are kind of hard to relate
to i mean his reproves corrections
instructions his warnings
even his punishments come from a heart
of love and any of us who've ever had
parents
know that our loving parents sometimes
reprove us
in punishment so
that really is something we have to keep
in mind at all times and so i asked the
question if god is love
can he be homophobic
because we are accused of when we use
the word of god we are accused of being
homophobic
well i like the word and i coined it
homogopic
i think god is homogopic
i know that the years that i was in the
gay culture myself
i know now god loved me very much
he loved me even though i was gay and he
didn't love me the way i was but he
loved me in spite of that
so i think that he is homogopic
and we should be too i mean i have
friends that are in the gay community
and
and and i love them and i have a burden
for their eternal life
when i left the lord in my youth
many years ago
i i wanted to be free from this
oppressive law that just says thou shalt
not thou shalt not i thought of it is
such a negative thing
i didn't stop to realize that james
refers to
the law of god as the perfect law of
liberty
uh in a couple places james 1 25 and
also james 2 10 to 12 the law of liberty
and so
as i look back on it now in my effort to
be
free from the law of god
i was seeking to be free from liberty
and if you're free from liberty where
does that leave you
doesn't that kind of kind of leave you
in bondage right i didn't realize that i
was leaving liberty and willfully going
into bondage interesting
now there's a text of scripture that
that is this was a pivotal a pivotal
text of scripture in my own conversion
uh first corinthians 6 9 to 11.
and it lists a number of of behaviors
that will not be in heaven
know ye not that the unrighteous shall
not inherit the kingdom of god
and then it says be not deceived and i
think this is very important
those three words be not deceived no
matter what books you read no matter
what you hear in the world no matter
what you hear in the church be not
deceived these behaviors will not be in
heaven
and among those behaviors is
homosexuality
but verse 11 was such this was a pivotal
verse and such were some of you
but ye are washed sanctified justified
in the name of the lord jesus and by the
spirit of our god so i look at the word
of god i mean to me
it is solid it gives me hope when i was
in the gay culture it gave me hope
it gave me direction it stomped on my
toes like crazy but i knew that i was
the one in error and
and i responded to the call of the word
of god
also in the word of god in hosea 4 6 i
think this is a very important passage
of scripture
god says my people are destroyed for
lack of knowledge
and in coming out ministries we have
kind of a three-pronged approach we want
to inspire the church
uh with our testimonies of deliverance
from the the gay culture we want to
enlighten the church by educating with
what we have learned through our study
and this program today is a part of the
enlightenment we also want to equip the
church and the lord is using us to
create resources
the like of which we would really have
appreciated in our youth had there been
such a thing in the church
but notice the next part of this verse
because thou hast rejected knowledge
i will also reject thee
friends that's a that's a fearful
warning right from god who is love right
yes
you know you're destroyed for lack of
knowledge but
but if you reject knowledge that is
available that i am making available in
my word
then i have no choice but to reject you
uh it's a fearful warning
and then this is one of my favorite
texts second timothy 3 15-17
all scripture is given by inspiration of
god
all scripture and is profitable for
doctrine which means teaching
for reproof for correction for
instruction in righteousness
you know that the man of god may be
perfect and truly furnished unto all
good works
i remember in one of my sermons one day
in church i was
i was apologizing to the congregation
because i felt like i
had come across too strong and just
stepping on toes
and one of my elders raised his hand and
interrupted my sermon and he would not
be overlooked
[Music]
and he announced the whole church he
said pastor ron
any time on any day i come to church and
my feet are not stepped on my toes are
not stepped on
i feel cheated so i thought well praise
god that's what scripture is for it is
to show us
where we need correction
now also peter talks about he says our
beloved brother paul
in all his epistles and which are some
things hard to be understood anyone
reading the epistles of paul can agree
with peter
some of paul's writings i think i think
it was his phd that made it so difficult
but some things are hard
to be understood
which they that are unlearned and
unstable rest or twist as they do also
the other scriptures under their own
destruction
you know what i'm hearing now even in
our own denomination
unfortunately
some of our theologians are actually
saying
that the writings of moses in the
writings of paul did not apply to us
today
look at this text right here right and i
know the writings of paul are hard to be
understood but i would not be here today
if it were not for that difficult right
writing of the apostle paul
it may be hard to understand but
spiritual things are spiritually
discerned and they can be understood and
i give paul a lot of credit for where i
am today
then in thessaloni ii thessalonians it
talks about those that perish because
they receive not the love of the truth
and what is truth but fact
when jesus says i'm the way the truth
and the life
jesus changes not facts cannot be
changed
facts or facts and truth is fact
and
if we do not love truth that means we
love a lie
and i don't think any of us would admit
that we want to be lied to and like
being lied to
for this cause god shall send them
strong delusion that they should believe
a lie
you know who believed not the truth but
had pleasure
in unrighteousness
and i think this is what we're looking
at when we're looking at this book
called unclobber unfortunately
one of my favorite commentators on
scripture has this to say
the plainest and simplest as well as the
most difficult passages
will be rested from their true meaning
there are those who select such portions
of scripture as best serve their purpose
interpret to suit themselves and then
present these to the people
whole bible should be given to the
people just as it reads
and if we cannot accept the bible just
as it reads are we not like a ship
without a sail and floundering on the
sea there has to be a line of truth if
there's no line there it's like how do
you know what's real and what's not are
you making that up as you go along it's
like there has to be something that
you're judging all that against
something that's reliable
whether you like it or not at least it's
solid that's right
and then when i look at this book on
clobber
the the author talks about why he wrote
this book and why he went to all of this
trouble
to
to take a look at all of these what he
calls clobber texts of scripture any
text that deals with homosexuality
he wanted them to mean something else
because as a little boy he and his
friends
like to play
or use a jacuzzi that belonged to this
she says good lady that lived across the
street
she was a lesbian but she was such a
good person he says well i i have to
quickly say the bible says there's none
non-righteous or none could but one
what i think he means was she was nice
now
you can be nice and still not be good
that's true right
what are the motives of your being nice
a lot of
good people are good for selfish reasons
and but in his young mind this woman was
so nice
and he knew she was a lesbian and he was
raised in the church and he couldn't
understand why god would keep good
people out of heaven
so he had this burden to search
scripture to see if he could
not interpret it in a way that would
accommodate this good lesbian woman that
he knew as a child
so his his methodology
was this and you know i have a degree in
theology and i learned all about how to
study the word and the proper way to
study the word uh and when you open the
word of god you're supposed to open with
a clean slate
what does god have to say to me today
what toe will get stepped on today
what reproof do i need today what
correction am i going to see today and
be willing to accept it
but this author went into his study with
an agenda which i just mentioned
he was looking for loopholes and ways to
justify what he wanted to believe
and then
you know the the term for interpreting
script is called exegesis
so i i coined another term called
exegetical gymnastics
and this is what i saw because he's a
pastor and he went he knows what
exegesis is
he went through exegetical gymnastics
to make the scripture fit what he wanted
to believe i mean it was like
worthy of the olympics i mean when you
when you
read the book
he approached scripture to find out to
find what he wanted
he was on a quest to make
the lgbt issue acceptable to the church
that was his method and he says right
here uh in his book
i want the lgbt person to hear
you are loved just as you are by god and
by me
the bible does not condemn them their
spot at the table is open that's what he
wanted and so he read scripture with
that already set in his mind that he was
going to find that so in essence what he
was doing he was interpreting scripture
in light of today's culture
but we are to evaluate today's culture
in light of scripture
it's a totally opposite approach and
when you're talking to someone of that
mindset
there's no communication there's no way
to resolve if you don't have the same
rule of faith and practice you cannot
resolve these issues
i i think that this is a really good
basic foundational understanding of how
to approach the bible with any topic
it's not just lgbt it's like this could
be applied to anything and that's that's
why i think this topic is really
important because it allows us to say
what does the bible really say about
this and are we willing to set aside our
emotions and all those things and go
with thus saith the word of god or are
we trying to bend it to basically make
it okay for us to do that because if i
think about that verse that you read in
corinthians um
all of a sudden it's like if you steal
if you if you're angry with your brother
you know there's a list of things that
are there that aren't just necessarily
homosexual if i do any of those things
i'm not going to make it into heaven and
so if i'm sitting there just bending the
bible to say okay well i like to steal
things so so i i'm just going to make it
sound like that's okay for me and i'm
gonna still make it into heaven you know
it's like i think there's
that's exactly a point uh the point that
we're making here because on page 25 of
his book
he says in these six passages now he
picked out six texts of scripture there
are more than six
he missed one
one very important one but there are he
says in these six passages we're dealing
with cultures and languages thousands of
years removed from our own
and we're looking for answers to complex
questions that in many ways are unique
to our time in history
and so like you scotty i ask could that
not be said of any and all scripture
what scripture is not thousands of years
old right what verse is not thousands of
years old but also what problem i mean
there's homosexuality in lots day and
you know and there's there's this is not
a modern cultural issue that only exists
today in corinth when paul was writing
that letter to corinth
i've i i picture him
you know kind of closing his eyes he's
in prison he's writing to corinth and
he's seeing individual people in the
church he said
this will not be in heaven this will not
be in heaven this he's naming the sins
of the people
in the church that had come out
victorious because as in such were some
of you he's not naming every sin or
every abomination he's looking at things
that were in the church and
homosexuality was one of those things
there's nothing new under the sun that's
right it's just repackaged i think isn't
it
i wonder if other cultures look at that
the same way because
other
groups of people have their own
scriptures or ancient documents and i
wonder if they look at those like oh
those are relevant now because that's
just old and we have a new culture so
let's talk to someone from islam and see
what they're yeah
no they don't change no
the the author also has these what i
call four drawn conclusions or false
premises
he just states homosexuality is not a
sin
jesus never addressed it but then when
when i heard him say read that he said
jesus never addressed it i had to say
wait a minute he does not know who jesus
is
the jesus that wrote
in sand and the dirt in the new
testament the sins of the people that
were wanting to stone mary
uh he's the same jesus that said before
abraham was i am
which is the i am of the old testament
that same finger wrote the ten
commandments on stone he doesn't
understand that
all of those
uh taboos or abominations in the old
testament were written by jesus
spoken directly
he just assumes that
that the lgbt is a
natural or a normal inclination
but then he's overlooking the fact that
we all
what is normal in all of us is fallen
human nature right we're drawn to
brokenness yes we're broken we're born
fallen so just because it's normal
doesn't make it right and i want to
premise that also with
there is a lot of straight broken sexual
people yes so this is not just a
homosexual issue this is a straight
broken we're messed up sexually period
it's a human issue we're talking about a
sin issue just across the board but it
really comes to light when you look at
the lgbt issue
it really exposes the whole
the whole premise here and then he says
the concept of sexual orientation is
completely foreign back in the old
testament bible times wow well the words
sexual orientation are not in scripture
the concept is certainly there if you
are reading honestly
but another conclusion is he says he
says that those who are born gay are
exempt from scriptural condemnation
so he just all of a sudden
makes a statement about people being
born gay he doesn't give any
documentation any scientific foundation
he just has people that are born gay are
exempt from scriptural condemnation he
says today we know that homosexuality is
a sexual orientation from birth but he
doesn't say why he knows that
talk about that here's the problem with
where that that accusation lies if i'm
born gay and i'm kept out of heaven
whose fault is it right exactly it's
your fault now god that's right and
who's the accuser in it satan is the
accuser opens the door to everything
else you know sorry i was born in
alcohol like therefore i'm exempt what
scripture says about i was born a
pedophilia yeah you know anything and
everything yeah just completely and you
mentioned pedophilia and it's true the
the pedophile community is now coming
forward saying that this is a
an inborn orientation
they're making the same claim we want
our rights but the gay community gets
really upset when you even talk about
pedophilia in the same context of
homosexuality
however i come from that background and
i know for a fact pedophilia is very
much involved in homosexuality
um another
false premise he says loving committed
mutual respecting gay relation
relationships are exempt from all
scripture against lgbt
so what is his authority
that's a point
he doesn't give authority these are
false premises there are four drawn
conclusions without any
any documentation and i'm going to look
at that here so let's look at this one
about born gay where does that whole
idea even come from
well first of all there are two
distinguished there's lots of study on
the born gay issue the genetics
that one of the most recent is from
these two distinguished scholars
lawrence
uh meyer or mayor is that your uncle no
uncle lawrence
there you go is it mayor
meyer meyer no i i know the mayor
john mayer ruined my my name okay
well then there's also paul mchugh and
they're from johns hopkins university
and they released a lengthy three-part
report that concludes there is not
sufficient evidence
to prove homosexuals and transgenders
are born in that condition
in other words their conclusion and
these are very prominent scientists
there is no gauging
they go on to say that the understanding
of sexual orientation is an innate
biologically fixed property of human
beings
the idea that people are born that way
is not supported by scientific evidence
so
and that's from the executive summary so
this thing about being born gay if it's
repeated often enough long enough loudly
enough frequently enough it becomes
believable
and that's what's happened not only that
it's also comforting
yeah because if you have this one
message that's telling you well your
only destination if you're gay is to go
to hell then if anyone comes with a
counter to that and says well you were
born this way so there's you know god's
going to exempt you from that then it's
you're in a vulnerable position to
accept that
you know
you know it's it's so
close
in in in its deception
to the original you think about it like
what did david said david said i was
born in iniquity like he admitted like
yes i am born this way i have this
problem but david didn't say okay
because i'm born in iniquity therefore
i'm excused for all of my behavior no he
went to god and said god has a solution
for my born and iniquity and god can fix
it so it's really interesting how
that's come you know full circle been
twisted around and it's like well you
don't need to look for help right which
is a very dangerous position to be in
because you you don't see your need of
jesus anymore well what david basically
was acknowledging was i was born in
fallen human nature yes yeah exactly
therefore i need a savior exactly right
exactly
the the
study goes on to say
the hypothesis that gender identity is
innate
uh fixed property
of human beings that is independent of
biological sex
uh yeah i read that is not supported by
scientific evidence
now who are these two men dr lawrence
mayor meyer meyer meyer
he is an epidemiologist trained in
psychiatry he's a professor of
statistics and biostatistics
and dr paul r mchugh
is arguably the most important american
psychiatry psychiatrist in the last half
century wow this is
authority this is documentation but this
is not all i have a whole study on this
that shows that studies have been done
on for decades on the bourne gay issue
studying identical twins that have the
same dna
if one twin is gay then the other one
logically should be gay if it's genetic
it's only like 7.7 percent concurrence
it's very very low
so where did it come from the born gay
idea
these two fellows
uh marshall kirk
uh and dr hunter madsen
invented back in 1985
um
one was uh see
kirk was a gay psychology major
and hunter was uh he had his phd in
politics
so you have psychology and politics
working together to create the born gay
hoax
it is a hoax and the reason for it
was uh
they wanted they came to the point that
they wanted
uh legal minority status
based upon the civil rights act of what
and the
gay activists learned that if they could
make a compelling case
that they were born gay they could
become eligible for minority status
as a suspect class
under the civil rights act
well the civil rights act has
three criteria for legal minority status
and one is they've suffered a long
history of discrimination that could be
said of the gay community
number two was they were powerless to
help themselves as a community they were
a very small minority the the actual
percentage was maybe two percent of the
population
recently it's now grown to like six
percent and there's a reason for that
because the issue is being glorified and
celebrated and legislated
but the third criteria was that they had
to be born that way
they did not fit that criteria and
that's why they decided we'll just say
it and if we say it use the media
you say it enough times say it loud
enough loud enough long enough
frequently enough use the media use
legislation use education then it'll be
believable and now
whenever we have a q a period in one of
our sessions
the question always comes up inside the
church what about those who are just
born gay you see we've now
drunk that kool-aid
the church is buying into that
and so we have to this is why we have to
show this
now i want to
tell you about this activist lesbian
activist camille paglia she's very well
known
in media circles
and i respect her she is a lesbian
activist but she is honest
homosexuality is not normal she said
on the contrary it is a challenge to the
norm nature exists whether academics
like it or not
and in nature procreation is the single
relentless rule
that is the norm our sexual bodies were
designed for reproduction
no one is born gay the idea is
ridiculous
homosexuality is an adaptation
not an inborn trait wow and she is a gay
activist
but she's honest yeah and i can respect
that you know the term the term should
be um i was born to choose
you know right
shows this way and then there was this
study in the journal of human sexuality
that found that
sexual orientation can be changed
and that psychological care for
individuals with unwanted same-sex
attractions
is generally beneficial
and research has not found any
significant risk of harm
so what is the key phrase in that
unwantedness
i mean i have met so many people
gay people that wish they were not gay
there is hope for them
but they are being brainwashed once gay
always gay if we can just help them see
that's not true
if you don't want to be gay there is a
way out if you don't want to drown
there's a lifeguard if you do want to
drown
there's a lifeguard but you don't have
to accept it you know that type of thing
well do you think that
that the unwanted attractions is because
they don't want to be outcasted by
society or because they genuinely don't
want to like the same sex
yes
see with me
i was that way i grew up with unwanted
same-sex attractions i didn't he didn't
connect the fact that i was sexually
molested at the age of four and
repeatedly in grade school and even in
the military i didn't connect those dots
at the time i didn't want to be gay but
i couldn't get it out of my head because
i was victimized by men
or older boys and that was my
introduction to sexual behavior
but
somehow i knew it was wrong but i was
programmed i was conditioned so yes it
was unwanted and with that unwanted
attraction when i found there was a way
out i said i'll take it
it wasn't it wasn't easy but it's doable
but this same activist camille paglia
goes on to say
is the gay identity so fragile that it
cannot bear the thought that some people
may not wish to be gay
sexuality is highly fluid and reversals
are theoretically possible
however habit is refractory
once the sensory pathways have been
blazed and deepened by repetition
a phenomenon obvious in the struggle
with obesity smoking alcohol and drug
addiction
see she recognizes it's an addiction
right helping gays to learn how to
function heterosexually if they wish
is a perfectly worthy aim
you have to respect her yeah you do yeah
because she's being honest
and she's choosing to live her gay life
she's comfortable with that but she also
respects the power of choice other
people's desires
and
she's not going to be dishonest with
scripture or science
um but you know you can show someone
that thinks that they were born gay and
you hear these people that say well i as
long as as far back as i can remember i
was sexually attracted to the same
gender
that should be a red flag
because little children shouldn't be
thinking sexually right
if a three-year-old is thinking about
sex a three-year-old has been involved
in sex in one way or another exposed to
it right and there are many ways that
they can be exposed without actually
being physically touched right
so
even then there are people that are
convinced they're just born that way
that's all they've ever felt and thought
so i love god's invitation that he makes
to every every person
you can be born again
except a man be born again he cannot
enter the kingdom of god john 3 3.
everyone
everyone coming to christ has to be born
again
we all have to give up something don't
we we all have to be changed that's
actually a really interesting connection
that i've i don't know if we've ever
talked about that on the show but just
the act of being born again
i mean gets around that whole issue
that's coming in what do we do with
people that are born this way well easy
good morning born again i mean
solved you see we didn't choose our
first parents we didn't choose our
circumstances but we can choose to be
born again
then who is our father then what
genetics do we claim
and we can become partakers of divine
nature through the exceeding great and
precious promises of god then we stop
blaming we stop justifying we start
living as a part of the kingdom of god
and i love it that jesus just a few
verses later says well don't be
surprised said be born again
marvel not that i said unto thee you
have to be born again
i think that's really neat
well
uh the other another one of those four
drawn conclusions about loving committed
mutual respecting gay relationships
exempt from all scripture against lgbt
well
there was an interesting study done by
mark werder and madison that published
in the male couple in 1984 a long time
ago
something interesting about them is they
the authors themselves were a homosexual
couple
one was a psychiatrist and the other
psychologist i think that's a really
interesting
dynamic i'd love to be a fly on a wall
there oh my goodness
you could just see the meats trying to
analyze each other i know what you mean
when you said that
but it says after much searching they
were able to locate 156 male couples
in relationships that have lasted up to
37 years
two-thirds of these people entered the
relationship expecting to be loyal to
one another
how many ended up being loyal to one
another
oh no i was gonna guess that
you're gonna guess five i was gonna
guess but no that's way worse than i was
gonna get only seven
and what's interesting about that is
none of those seven had been together
more than five years
so that kind of indicates that loyalty
does not really
last very long it and i would not go so
far as to say that there are no loyal
gay couples but that's not the norm
in that community
so this author is talking about these
loving loyal committed gay couples like
every gay christian
is that way no
they tend to redefine terms monogamy now
is used to include
gay couples that agree to have sex
sexual recreational sex outside of their
relationship they still call it monogamy
that study goes on to say the single
most important factor
that keeps couples together past the
10-year mark is the lack of
possessiveness they feel in other words
to be able to have
recreational sex outside of that
there's so much we can say about all of
this um
about gay marriage and so forth the uh
there's
michelangelo signed riley who
talks about redefining the institution
of marriage completely he calls marriage
an archaic institution
this was before the supreme court ruling
their agenda was to redefine marriage to
radically
alter it and this lady here
masha gessen who is
very well known also as a journalist
she says that the institution of
marriage should not exist we were lying
about
what we want
uh with gay marriage
it's not compatible
with the institution of marriage what
they want
i suppose we live in a world that god is
allowing us to choose which path we want
and sometimes there's a lot of times
people are going to choose a path
contrary to what god designed for us
right but he allows us that space right
so it's interesting to me that they're
like yeah oh marriage is terrible and oh
it's old and it shouldn't be done it's
like you're going to slam on that but
then ask for the freedom to do whatever
you want over here and it's like why
can't you just say hey if you're into
marriage and that's what you want to do
then then great i'm going to go over
here and do my thing yeah i almost
wouldn't have as much as an issue of
that because i think god allows us to
have that freedom but it's like when
they all of a sudden slam this
institution say oh this is this is
junk
if you said that about gay marriage
they'd be
upset you know well the reason for it is
they want all of the privileges that go
along with marriage the legal rights and
benefits but if they destroy the
institution of marriage then everyone
equally gets benefits
so like hospital visitation and all that
type of thing
there's so many different
things that married uh rights that
marriage married couples have that the
gays didn't have
but they just want that to be free for
everybody
and masha gessen herself
is in a very strange or was in a very
strange relationship where
she had she and her partner had
children with various men and they
wanted all of them to be considered a
marriage unit
which is polygamy or polyamory actually
but god's plan
spelled out very clearly in his word and
there again we need to be very thankful
for his word it gives us
the the parameters in which we can live
for health happiness fulfillment and joy
and all of that
and spelled out in genesis 2 about
the man leaving father and mother and
cleveland and his wife
they too shall be one flesh
and that's god's plan
now that another uh forward-drawn
conclusion was god loves you just the
way you are
and i hear that all the time god loves
you just the way you are and i have to
say wait a minute
if god loves me just the way i am
why are we told be transformed
by the renewing of your mind it's
interesting right
i say god loves us in spite of the way
we are
he does love us unconditionally i say
unconditionally
but he loves us in spite of the way we
are
and he says be transformed by the
renewing of your mind
everyone coming to christ goes through
what they what is called conversion
we go which means change we
what is a change all about it's about
being changed into the image of christ
so that means that that god loves us and
wants to
create us recreate us into his image the
plan of salvation i think is about being
restored to his original plan that's why
he says in second corinthians 5 17
therefore if any man be in christ he is
a new creature
old things are passed away all things
are become new
there's some interesting commentary on
that too
uh that i really like it says the new
birth consists in having new motives
new tastes and new tendencies and a
genuine conversion actually changes both
hereditary and cultivated tendencies to
wrong
and there is science scientific basis
for that we don't have time to go into
that but there is a scientific basis for
how the mind
readjusts and old pathways can atrophy
and die and new ones being created
so and
yes i have a question so what
would you say
is
i guess the end result
of
because it's like it seems like
when you're gay
the church presents two options god's
either gonna turn you heterosexual or
you're gonna be single forever and i
think relations relationships are so
important to us i feel like it's at the
center of who we are god himself is
relational so i guess what would you say
to someone who is trying to navigate
between those two options like what if
they just feel like they're not
attracted to women at all or two men at
all like the same sex at all but then
you know um yeah i guess you know it
would be interesting to do a study in
the church to find out how many people
are single period
why do the gays get a license
to hook up
but
straits do not
if a man and a woman
decide to
have a relationship outside of marriage
that's forbidden but it then too there
are many straight people christians that
have never found a spouse
they're not to have sexual relations
outside of marriage either
so i like to put them all in the same
basket there are many reasons people are
single
and
same-sex attractions are one
but then there are those that have just
never found anyone that they
find to be a right fit
and there are many ways to have intimacy
in life without
involving oneself in sin
uh and
uh heterosexuality is not um
a heterosexual marriage is not for
everyone
i myself the the same year that i came
out of the gay culture and was baptized
the same year i was married we've been
married for 29 years now
and we have
two children together but we have five
all together and four grandchildren
i took my homosexuality in my mind i did
a mental exercise i hung it on the
forbidden tree in the garden of eden
and you know the fruit on that tree must
have been delectable or eve wouldn't
have been tempted right
and i say just no matter how delectable
that fruit it's on the wrong tree
it's off limits it's no longer an option
i turn my back on that and i say lord
would you ever trust me again with
family
and i just gave him permission to work
in my life in that way and
within a year i was married and we have
a family but not everyone has
marriage is not the solution i'll tell
you
marriage is not the solution to the gay
problem i tried that
my first time around and it was a
disaster
it only added to my confusion
so
jesus is the solution
and the intimacy that we may not have in
a
marriage relationship
jesus wants us to have an intimate
relationship with him
and he fills the void in our lives
for for whatever reason when we lose a
parent or we lose a spouse
or we haven't found a spouse jesus can
fill all the voids in our lives
some interesting terms that this author
uses he uses the term oversaved
i thought that how can you be oversaved
if i'm drowning and someone yanks me out
of the
sea and you save me too much oversaved
a little bit of water left in my lungs
or what
and and here's the definition that he
gives someone who is too religious
too focused upon one's faith and too
eager to share that faith with others
wow and i hope everyone at this table is
oversaved
under that definition i think i think
paul would definitely fit this
discretion wouldn't he i mean he spoke
to his own personal detriment many times
but you know for a pastor to use that
term about being oversaved i think most
of us
should be concerned about being
undersaved
right
and then he talks about the open
inclusive affirming church affirming
christians which means
really legally to ratify or accept
and his burden is to get all churches or
to get the church to just affirm and
ratify homosexuality
into membership in the leadership
and all of that but that's
um
a real push in the church
in the church today
he says no matter who you are you are a
loved and accepted child of god and may
you have eyes to see that everyone
around you is also a loved and fully
accepted child of god
what he doesn't understand is
yes we are loved god loved us while we
were yet sinners while we're enemies he
died for us before we were born
but acceptance with god is conditional
upon an entire surrender of the will
because when you're accepted of god what
are you being accepted into
if you're we're very close to a
university here there are conditions to
be accepted into that
school
there are conditions to remain in that
school there are conditions
to being accepted into a job or a career
or a club
and conditions to
remain in that
and so
with jesus when we are accepted by him
we are accepted into the school
of discipleship
to become like him their conditions to
being accepted we have to be submissive
to his being lord
and master
and you think about the meaning of those
words how many of us
really
allow him to truly be lord and master
and render him unconditional and
cheerful obedience
so so can you be gay and christian
good question oh what a question
i call that an oxymoron
because in first corinthians 6 verse 9
it mentions all of these people who will
not be in heaven
and he says such were some of you
so if you are a gay christian
to me that says i am
a christian who will not be in heaven
[Music]
and how can you be a gay christian see
you're launching me to another sermon
about the prefix christian
if you're a gay christian what is first
gay or christ right
gay i can understand it if you remove
the because there's a lot of emotion
that i think is centered around that
question right um so if you remove
yourself from that question and you
actually get to a different place where
you're like am i a thiefing christian
right am i a lying christian right am i
all these other things like you're
taking my prefix
sermon
so you're preaching so yeah you would
you wouldn't actually have that
as as as you would say that's okay but
then all of a sudden like we're
redefining this thing to saying well
just because of all the
emotion and it's who we are and blah
blah blah well who we are is really
liars
but doesn't it take cause i'm sure the
process of conversion is not something
that happens overnight no so it's like
and and i know as well it's
the practice of thieving the practice of
homosexuality the practice of lying you
know but it's like what if you identify
as gay let's just say in the beginning
you identify as gay
but you really do want to pursue jesus
you do have a heart for jesus or for
ministry you're still trying to balance
out the two but it's like
you know you you consider yourself a
christian but you're still gay
well this is such a good question i wish
we had an hour to talk about it but i'll
just say this when i left the gay
culture
i not only turned my back on
homosexuality but smoking and drinking
and drugs and all those things
i do not refer to myself as a
non-practicing pothead christian right
if i'm not practicing why
wear the badge
if jesus came to save you from sin and
homosexuality is a sin issue
don't go around wearing the badge of the
thing he's saving you from wear his
badge say i'm a christian
i struggle with many things but i'm not
going to identify with
satan's plan for my life i'm going to
identify with god's plan for my life the
the gay thing is satan's plan don't give
him credit and
what i also practice was to starve the
old
and feed the new
and as a man thinketh in his heart or a
young lady
so is he if you every time you say i'm a
gay christian
you're that's negative reinforcement
yeah um
it's like when you say i'm an alcoholic
and you haven't had a drink for 20 some
years why don't you just say i used to
be
can't you say i used to be and yes i i
could be tempted but
people have asked me
were you ever tempted after you're
baptized did god just take that away and
i said well wait a minute
i was baptized satan wasn't
he's the tempter
i have no control of what he throws at
me but i do have control with how fast i
threw it back
right and we have we are equipped to be
able to
deal with temptation but just realize
that those same-sex attractions come
from temptation
and
propensities are habits
so we may have a propensity in that area
because we had a habitual life in that
area but we don't need to identify with
the thing we want freedom from
if we identify with it we're never free
from
it and somebody identifies the new
creature in christ that's exactly where
i was going to go is where you went you
know when jesus came he said um you
shall name his name jesus because he's
here to save the people from their sins
so if we get to the point where it's
like well i want to attach myself to
jesus because he just
he just accepts me and that's all we're
looking for is acceptance
then you can go find that 100 places
what you can't find is somebody who will
save you from your sin and transform you
and if you're going to follow somebody
like that there's no point in following
them if you're not all in right
so exactly or there's no growth
happening either yeah and then you know
to kind of further address your point
it's like you're you're asking like well
what about the person that's in the
process
let god sort it out right you know don't
worry about the labels let god sort it
out and and god will figure it out and
and god will make the change yeah once i
left the gay culture i never identified
with gay
it didn't mean i didn't have temptation
that i would not allow myself to be
labeled
i don't
label myself by the nature of my
temptations why
jesus was tempted in all points like as
me yet without sin
what's his name
yeah right
don't let temptation determine your
orientation
orientation is the direction you're
going
not the direction
here's my book
not the direction the winds are trying
to push you
my new book is called navigating the
storms of contemporary sexuality
and it's based on my solo cross-country
flight as a student pilot right out here
at college
and i got caught in a storm flying from
collegedale to
huntsville alabama and in huntsville to
nashville
and oh my the object lessons that come
out of that
but i didn't allow the storm to dictate
my landing
i flew out of the storm i had to
reorient
recalibrate with a map in one hand and
eyeballs on the ground trying to figure
out where i was and i finally found
things that matched then i recalibrated
flew to nashville safely landed flew
back to college jail and landed safely
so we don't allow temptation
to determine our direction and our
orientation orientation is the direction
we choose to go and that we're going
can we give away one of your books
sure
you want it no well if you guys want one
of these books we'll put a link in the
description of where you can buy it but
um if you want i don't know how we can
do a giveaway but yeah we can do a
giveaway we'll just set it up on our
website like the others okay okay so
well let's look real quickly at the
collaboratex and i'm going to do this
real quickly because it's i've
well we're running out of time for one
thing but
genesis 19 the story of sodom and
gomorrah is referred to a clobber text
and the author says i don't believe that
the story is literal perhaps it's both
myth and history why doesn't he believe
he's basically saying i don't believe in
the word of god
isn't he
he he says
it's
he calls the author a storyteller
a storyteller i think it tells of gang
rape and in hospitality i think it's
also interesting to a point that he
doesn't believe this so if there's no
real science or anything that's based on
that it's like he doesn't want to
believe it no
and when you look at the sins of sodom
that are spelled out in the bible and
i'll just run through some of them pride
fullness of bread
didn't help the poor they were haughty
they committed abomination fornication
going after strange flesh you know one
of the terms that is used or it was very
common when i was in the gay culture
someone that is tricking which means
going for a new person every experience
maybe a new
conquest
they call it going after strange yeah
that's right out of jude seven they
don't realize they're quoting the sins
of sodom when they say i'm going after
strange oh wow it's right there he
doesn't mention that it's a clobbered
text but it's in there
he calls abominations when when god
talks about abomination he says well
these are just cultural taboos
what's that i like that you're
clarifying that because i think this the
story of sodom and gomorrah is always
what people use to like
um prove homosexuality right to ju to be
judgmental to be hateful to say like
this is the worst sin ever
um and god's gonna destroy you that's
always what i think there's a whole list
of abominations adultery is an
abomination
you know one that god especially hates
well pride of course but sowing discord
among the brethren that's abomination
i think that may be in the church but
and he calls abomination
abomination
is not in and of itself a sufficient
reason for us in the 21st century to
to turn against homosexuality or preach
against it
and all these other abominations and
idolatry and impure sacrifice occultic
practices
wearing that which pertains to the
opposite gender that's called
abomination you want to get into a
discussion
certain remarriages to former spouses
dishonesty perverse behavior here a
proud look a lying tongue murder wicked
imaginations mischief false witness that
speaks lies
he that sows discord among the brethren
so many abominations in the bible
justifying evil and condemning the just
that's what's happening today oh yeah
that's in our government it's in the
media it's in schools it's in church
that very thing is very alive and well
and adultery
another clobber text is leviticus 18 and
leviticus 20
it says if a man lie with mankind is
with a woman
then
he both of them have committed an
abomination
the author just dismisses that as
priestly restrictions leviticus is a
book for the priests
it's a priestly restriction against
blurring the boundaries of israelite
identity
whatever that means is it second peter 2
9 or 1st peter 2 9 it says that we are a
royal priesthood right yeah yeah
that's right there you go and he doesn't
that's a very good point i'm going to
have to really go into my presentation
you heard it here first yeah
i'll have to add that in
romans 1 is another clobbered text that
talks about the lusts of their own
hearts
vile affections even their women
and the men leaving the natural use of
the woman burning their lust one toward
another men with men and so forth
new testament uh yes this is the new
testament and he says this is a passage
intended to expose jewish prejudice and
reconcile the roman church oh wow and i
don't see that anywhere in there no
he says we do not provide a blanket
condemnation of homosexuality nor give
biblical grounds to condemn any and all
same-sex sex acts
so i mean he's saying these verses do
not in other words he's
he's saying any and all same-sex acts
can be okay any and all wow
so now he's gone away from committed
loyal right uh relationships and i'm
saying any and all right see he's lost
his consistency there
so
he says it was culturally shameful for
that day
but not the same for the church and
culture today
but what about the culture of the
kingdom of god so culture dictates now
what is right and wrong that's that's a
big gray area there so what is the rule
of faith and practice
culture or scripture yeah we believe
scripture that's right and he believes
culture so what would you say to someone
who's saying well how can a god of love
and also who supports choice
would go and destroy people who are
choosing to live that way you know and
if he if he loves that if he's a god of
love how can he just destroy people like
that
well in revelation read about the lake
of fire where the wicked will be
destroyed is it because god does not
love them
no
they don't love him back
he
sin cannot exist in the presence of a
holy god
and if we hang on to it we'll be
consumed with it when he reveals himself
in his glory
uh it's not that he doesn't love us
it's that we're consumed the wages or
consequences of sin is death in other
words
when we choose to sin we're choosing to
unplug disconnect from the source of
life
and
uh
it's it's going to be the natural result
um
when you hear about read about satan
being destroyed by fire a fire comes
from within
uh somehow in the presence of god
he just ignites
it's not a matter of love
and not loving
he loves
that's why we started out god is love
and he's homogopic he's not willing that
any should perish
but many will i've always thought of it
also in terms of justice because when
someone does bad in our society we want
them to have the worst punishment but
it's like when god does it it's like oh
well that's a problem but it's like
naturally we all want a perfect world
standard exactly so you think about god
he's perfectly he's merciful and just
but justice cannot exist without mercy
true justice and mercy cannot exist
without true justice
look at all of the victims
of of sin
the victims of crime
god would not be merciful to the victims
if justice was not meted out
so he's perfectly balanced in that
regard
the author's conclusions basically are
essentially the same as his foregone
conclusions so i don't really need to
go through them in great detail
he says consensual sex is beautiful and
not sinful it's a gift from god
consensual sex what about marriage
but he just said also all right so so
now he's saying consensual yeah that's
uh and there's no right i mean i mean a
couple of you know 13 year olds i mean
yeah all is a scary scary where are the
parameters they're not there is none and
therefore he says homosexuality and
heterosexuality can be sinful
sometimes yes
sometimes no
so in other words it's like anything
goes almost and love has to exist and
who
who determines that that's the que
that's the thing in question i think you
are if you've got into yourself yeah if
you're saying sometimes it does and
sometimes it doesn't then who makes that
decision
if it's consensual or not and then he
says you can be a gay and christian
answer your question
yes he promotes gay christian
um
but if you say pedophile christian
oh my can you imagine going into church
saying you know i i'm a non-practicing
pedophile but i'd really like to have
leadership role in the church and i i
really like working with children
you know i'm a sex trafficker that's all
i mean yeah but i i'm not practicing but
that's who i am you'd be assigned some
deacons real fast yeah
he says some gays are card-carrying
spirit-filled fruit-producing flowers of
jesus
but there's no basis for that now this i
really want to get this in
he says i can only imagine how it must
feel for a gay person to come out of the
actual closet
desperate to be seen to be heard to be
trusted to be accepted and to be loved
now
i altered that quote
i turned it around the way it should be
and this is what i came up with
i can only imagine how jesus must feel
desperate to be seen
desperate to be heard to be trusted to
be accepted as lord and master and
savior from sin and to be loved he says
if you love me
keep my commandments
see the focus is different one focuses
upon self
i am desperate to be seen to be heard to
be accepted to be loved and jesus says
well wait a minute so am i
i'm desperate
i came to save you to give you eternal
life i am desperate to save you i want
you with me for all eternity and i'm
desperate for that to happen
so what is our focus
it should be upon him so one focus is
upon feelings and emotions
of oneself
the other is focus upon the feelings and
emotions of jesus christ
and we need to put him first
the author concludes his book by saying
neither do i condemn thee
and he puts a period there
but the very next phrase he leaves out
go and sin no more
and i have been told that we are not to
use go and sin no more that is hate
speech
so why can jesus say neither do i
condemn thee in love
but go and sin no more because i hate
you it does not make sense yeah it's the
same sentence it's not a
conversation it's the same sentence yeah
so i i just have a few concluding
thoughts here myself uh back to that uh
commentary before it's actually from the
great book the great controversy page
598 it says the language of the bible
should be explained according to its
obvious meaning
unless a symbol or figure is employed
christ is given the promise if any man
if any man will do his will he shall
know of the doctrine
if men would but take the bible as it
reads
if there were no false teachers to
mislead and confuse their minds a work
would be accomplished that would make
angels glad and that would bring into
the fold of christ thousands upon
thousands who are now wandering in error
wow so
we need to remember proverbs there is a
way which seemeth right unto a man like
this author yeah but the end thereof
are the ways of death
and again jeremiah 17 9 the heart is
deceitful above all things who and
desperately wicked who can know it we
cannot look to self for answers we must
look to an authority a
an authority an unchanging authority
and then the lord is not slack
concerning his promise some encounters
but is long-suffering to us we're not
willing that any should perish not any
gay person no but that all should come
to repentance
and then
i like to close with this little
um
which let's say it's a
medley of texts
god is love
nothing is impossible with him amen for
he is mighty to save
the whosoevers
from whatsoever
even to the uttermost i love it
[Laughter]
amen can we make a t-shirt out of that
that'd actually make a really cool
t-shirt
actually that would be great i i like to
close with that awesome and i know i i
went really fast through this because of
time
that i appreciate the time and your
questions were
really good that every question that was
asked
brought to my mind a whole sermon that i
had
i wrote a book called straight answers
to the gay question or the lgbt question
having been there
and
it's really quite comprehensive because
i dealt with questions for
many years on my website and finally i
realized i'm just answering the same
questions over and over let's put it all
together in a book
so it's a very very neat book straight
answers to the gay question well ron
it's been a pleasure to have you on our
show i hope that we can have you again
and uh wow what a wealth of information
you have been to
this subject
and for you guys out there
please we'll put a link into their
website in in the description below and
check out some of the books that he's
written he has done a lot of work in
this area they have traveled around the
world been in many many different
countries trying to help our church
understand some of these important
topics and so uh ron thank you for
coming and blessing us we will give a
giveaway um so uh how do we let people
know about that the link will be in the
description below the link will be in
the description below and then you can
get one of his books but uh check out
coming out ministries great ministry
they've got a lot of content online they
made a documentary that was amazing
called journey interrupted and it was a
beautifully well done documentary of the
stories behind some of the people that
work in um coming out ministries so um
ron thank you for for for blessing us
with today's topic and if you guys have
any comments or questions of course
leave them below
if you're new to our channel check out
some of our other content and also like
and subscribe if you know someone that
would benefit from this type of content
please share this video with them it
does no good sitting on our shelves
please we wanted to go out to as many
people as possible and we love you and
thank you for coming by today and we
hope that you'll come again thank you
and we'll see you next week
[Music]
foreign